hi everyone my name is Matt I will go
ahead and get started today I'm gonna be
talking about and a rather insane
request I realize at a conference of
this nature I wonder if there's an
indulgence to me if you have a laptop if
you wouldn't mind closing it it's kind
of eerie to look out and just see like
screens lighting onto people's faces and
not make eye contact with anyone so
today I'm gonna talk about some of the
ways that you can plot with pandas and
with ipython and feel free to ask
questions as we're going I'll leave some
time at the end for it right and I will
try and leave time at the end for
questions is this better
one more all right
so brief background I'm working on this
project called plotly we have a number
of api's most prominently our Python API
for making plots directly from Python
and from pandas you can do maps and all
manner of other plots and 3d plots but I
think that's less interesting than
showing how people who are using it or
actually using it in their Python
workflow so I'm gonna show four
different people's plots and how they're
making them and what they're using them
for and how they're using Python and
pandas first is this developer named
Jorge who works for Thomson Reuters and
he recently wrote this wrapper between
plotly and pandas called cufflinks that
lets you plot directly from a data frame
second is a professor who is a
mathematician and
uses plotly for some pretty cool plots
that we'll look at third is a data
scientist at Salesforce who makes some
awesome 3d plots that we can look at and
fourth is a writer who writes for Wired
named ret Alain who writes about physics
and also makes some pretty sweet plots
so a lot of this is enabled because of
ipython notebooks so not going to go
super deep into that one
but it's what most of the the plots that
we'll be looking at are made with so
cufflinks is a pretty cool first glance
at this where you can essentially set up
a data frame and call I plot from within
your notebook and that plots the data
frame so that gives me within the
notebook interactivity and it's rendered
with d3.js which is the JavaScript
library that Mike Bostock wrote for the
New York Times and once you call I plot
that's actually of has a function that
wraps the plot inside of an iframe which
is kind of one of the cool things about
the notebooks is you can support iframes
within them so when we respond with the
URL from a request we just wrap it in an
iframe function and then put it directly
into the notebook and so that's how you
can kind of get interactivity and it
handles daytime's we can drag and toggle
and move around and jorge has hooked
this up too so he works for Thomson
Reuters and uses this with some of the
other folks on his team and they've
hooked this up for a number of different
api's that they have for calling in
finance data and one of the cool things
about it that he does and that he told
us about is he uses it to sort of
productionize his workflow because from
within you know his ipython notebook
he'll make plots and then be able to
share just the plot and use it as a
dashboard so
then other folks can come in and edit
the plot directly from either the
notebook if they have their own ipython
back-end or you can just take the plot
and bring it into a GUI and from within
the GUI we have you know styling options
and you can set your own templates and
defaults and then the whole thing runs
like Google Docs in that you can just
sort of share add collaborators and then
the link itself once you've made the
plot has and so here I sort of worked my
own version and it maintains the data
behind it and the code with it so even
though we made this with Python I can
get the our script to reproduce it or
the JSON object or just call an image or
the way that they use it there you can
just embed it and then put it into HTML
elsewhere as an iframe to make it as you
know to embed it inside of dashboards or
reports or something so it's pretty cool
because he has hooked up a lot of
different chart types to a lot of
different aspects of the what now you do
with pandas plotting and also with
matplotlib for the art matplotlib figure
converter so you can go through and see
all of these different plot types that
you can plot from pandas and a lot of
this heap is pushed out in the past like
two weeks which is why I thought it
would be a fun thing to just show for
this conference and it's so you can get
box plots histograms sub plotting areas
scatters bubbles matrices sub plotting
and wherever
yeah and then shapes so that's sort of
our first our first look at how someone
is using pandas with ipython and it's
pretty cool pretty cool example that I
enjoy this is a second one this is an
example that shows the new default color
maps for matplotlib which is pretty
sleek and here we so we have it as a
default inside like our API that you can
call but from here she just rebuilt it
and you can see it in action here with a
contour plot or with one of these guys
get a little little streamlines and then
this is the one that I think is really
fun this is 3d so we can zoom and then
you can see the latech that goes with it
and it's pretty cool so she emailed this
to me like two or three days ago and
it's pretty sweet because she's made
some really awesome plots all again
using the same color scales and so it's
pretty fun because you can apply all of
these different color scales front and
then save them and then all of it is
just part of your ipython notebook and
lets you do all of this from just like
within the notebook and then we have an
offline version of plotly that you can
run directly inside of your notebooks if
you want to do offline plotting third
example well before that does anyone
have any questions yes yeah yes so we we
give so we've we've essentially gone
with like the github approach on it so
you can do unlimited free public
plotting on our cloud and then we do an
enterprise distribution for people who
want to host a server or just an offline
version that just runs inside ipython or
MATLAB or our studio
yep yeah and you I'm happy to talk
afterwards if you want on it so these
are plots that I just saw on Friday and
really got me excited this these are a
series of plots that a data scientist at
Salesforce showed me that he's working
on where they're doing some pretty cool
3d clustering and let's look at it let's
get a full screen of this so we have so
you can set any of the and this is all
just right he's just done all this with
Python and running inside their ipython
and so it's pretty fun because you can
actually set a specific hover text
object as well for 3d so right here
you'll see you get like XYZ on the
cluster but then below it you can get
specific identification markers which is
the fourth line down so the XYZ
variables are just automatically
generated based on your orientation to
the data and then the spikes that run
out to the edges show you your
orientation to the other three axes but
you're actually able to set a custom
variable which is pretty fun so like an
example of this that's a little easier
to look at is this is the 3d data or the
prestige dataset if any of you have used
this from our and so it's similar
concept kind of shows you like what what
he's doing but just this this one has
the actual text markers on top of it
that also show up in the hover text so
it's pretty cool because then we can you
know filter again and turn traces off
and on and so you can kind of use it as
a way to explore things in 3d and I've
really been hoping that someone perhaps
even here would make would use some of
this 3d plotting to be able to make a
solar system simulation
and so if anyone here wants to talk
about that we have a couple people
who've taken first passes at that and I
think that would be a pretty awesome
graph to make so but yeah so this guy
Chuck makes these pretty incredible
plots that they use where they take hide
dimensional data an incredible amount of
it and then drop it down to use cohort
analysis and to cluster it and then push
it in from pandas dataframes
and then just plot it directly from
pandas dataframes other questions yes
this is plotly mm-hmm yeah so we have I
mean so it's all of it is is binding and
we have like wrappers around like mat
plot live and Seabourn and stuff like
that but this is run it so we use d3 and
WebGL and this is our our rendering for
it and so it's just all it's just all
browser-based but we have also this is
you mentioned Seabourn so we have a
matplotlib figure converter T that we've
been working on so this is using this is
a map plot live figure here and then
from there you can call I plot MPL which
calls the figure object and takes the
matplotlib figure and then redraws it
and so we got interactivity and you can
like you know specify zooms that you
want to have here and then you can you
know if you want to sort of like the
same workflow that we showed earlier get
that within a GUI and then be able to
edit it and add Fitz and stuff like that
and then share it with other people like
Google Docs and so we've been able to do
that for an increasing number of plot
types from matplotlib and then
from pretty plot lib and then from this
is with Seaborn
but rendering it then with plotly and
then you can get like the filtering and
stuff like that that goes with it but so
it's this is using plot lays cloud-based
service for it other questions I love
questions I used to be a high school
teacher so feel free to bring on the
questions if you have more of them yes
so I didn't quite hear you
back to matplotlib know we can't go back
to matplotlib but you can go back to
python so we like the way that we've set
things up is all of our API czar
wrappers around our REST API and then we
translate it up and down essentially
because so everything is JSON based and
so then when you're and that's like we
have like a JavaScript library too and
it's the same approach where you can
bring in you know drop in JSON objects
as data but then going back down to
syntax from the specific library is kind
of tough so we have like a figure
converter for ggplot2 and we have kind
of the same thing where you can go back
to our Python that lets you replicate it
I'll show you the code for that but we
can't go directly back down to
matplotlib but the code for the the
Python code for it shows me a fully
reproducible version of that plot
because it actually just has the data as
an element within it so when I go so
that plot was made with matplotlib and
now here is the Python syntax for how to
make that with plot lays api that
contains the data and then it also shows
you that you know the colors and the
layout and all of the other information
from it other questions yes
it's so we will render it so we you send
it to the server if you're using our
cloud product and if you're not using
like the offline version or the
Enterprise version you send it up we
send it back down and then we'll just
render it on the client and so
everything because since we use JSON
this like we when we store the
description for it it's just one long
JSON blob that describes the whole plot
and then we send it back down and render
the plot for you yeah yes the question
is do we have integration with ipython
widgets have folks in here used ipython
widgets anyone they yeah I figured you I
figured the questionnaire might have
they are awesome so one really cool
thing about ipython wedges and this is
just a series of gifts here but you can
get this and run these notebooks so we
have I I pi thon widgets let you build
in all kinds of cool functionalities of
like sliders and widgets and stuff like
that directly into your notebook with
Python and so it's pretty cool because
it kind of lets you set up like
interactive templates or dashboards or
filtering or whatever kind of stuff you
want so this is a example of doing
widgets with sliders let me get this
really big and so we can do that right
inside of an eye Python notebook this is
using by the way if you ever like making
gifts there's this tool called gift
brewery that lets you make a QuickTime
video something and turn it right into a
gif it's pretty handy for like taking if
you want to make and it's like show
someone how to do something just makes
it real fast gift for you so this is
making a fractal tree we can do
lighters that show frequency with
widgets you can do topographies with
point-and-click functionality and this
one was pretty fun so this you can even
load pandas dataframes into it into a
set of like and setup widget
functionality around it and so you can
actually like search direct like have a
search box that's running inside your
notebook and lets you search the data
frame that you have behind it which is
like pretty pretty nuts experience a lot
of times when I think you know I used to
think of ipython and I'd be curious to
hear with you how you guys describe it
I used to describe it because so my my I
was a philosophy major in college and my
parents still don't really believe that
I have a job and like so when I first
told him about ipython I was like it's
like tumblr but for coding but now I've
moved on to saying it's like it's kind
of like the Internet
but easier but I can't really come up
with a good description for it but the
new widgets kind of take it to the next
level I think in a lot of ways because
you can do all kinds of crazy stuff and
like just all from within your notebook
interface so like this is an example of
that where you can just like set up
widgets and sliders to let you sort for
date ranges and just run all of this
inside of your notebook one thing I was
going to point out to you a service and
integration that I enjoy and that we
work with is there's this company called
Domino that does hosted notebooks that
I've started using a lot it's pretty
cool because you can share notebooks
directly with other folks because
they're just running it on their on
their cloud so if someone else doesn't
have their own I PI thon backend you can
just send you know point them towards
the the repo that you've made there in
the you know in the same way that you
might do that with like it when you're
publishing notebooks from github does
that answer your question Brian
great other questions yes yeah
so we plotly is we're like a year and
almost two years old we are based in
Montreal and then of some people
distributed around in other places as
well and the the goal behind it has
always been to be able to support
collaborative cloud-based plotting and
then also I mean we we got started on it
because we love github and wanted to be
able to do with have the same workflow
available for plotting and data analysis
as you have for coding if you're using
github so we we have all of our API s
and our figure converters are open
source and so if you check out our
github you can find a lot of our
different and like we try and open
source as many of our projects as we're
working on so we have like a publisher
which is pretty cool so you can take
ipython notebooks and convert them
directly into github pages so we write
all of our documentation on plotly is
actually just or almost all of it for
like our yeah yeah we just use ipython
notebooks for our documentation and then
it's pretty cool because you can just
you know convert them into HTML so we
have you know any of the projects that
we're working on like that any of our
api's are open source and then we
maintain the central core of plotly
because that's what lets us have like a
feed and collaboration and stuff like
that
so I mean I think we'd like to do more
open source in the future right now it's
you know we're like 20 people on the
team and it's still super early so we're
trying to figure out how to how to make
that work but you know of our API s and
figure converters and
of our projects are on github and we
actually and that's been incredible for
us because just it's it's amazing how I
mean you know I don't have to say that's
what people in this room but it's really
been cool to see like people come in and
who we've never talked to who just like
submit a pull request they're like oh
this broke
I think this fixes everything that I I
was having problems with and I'm just
like wow that's that's incredible but
you know it's like kind of the power of
being able to to do stuff like that but
yeah just do that answer your question
do you have cool yeah we have if you're
interested in seeing lots of graphs if
you get a plot ly / feed you can see
graphs that people are publishing and
sharing and be able to check those out
all right let's see here final one so
this is there's this writer named rat
who uses plot Li and he will just embed
his plots inside of his wired articles
in iframes
so for example he did this experiment
here where he was looking for 1964
silver quarters and then once he had and
so his he like got hundreds of quarters
and then plotted all of the different
years that he had gotten them for and so
he'll just embed all of his charts
inside of his wired articles and that
then lets him have like you know
interactive plots inside of Wired
without him having to use like
JavaScript embed it because it all just
runs inside of iframes so as an example
of how quickly you can do that I think
this is a fun one to do so these are
ribbon plots here let's grab the chart
so here we just get the embed snippet
for it plotly uses a tumbler for our
blog I'll just throw this in here
we'll place this privately because it's
not her best post and then once you've
published this it lets me publish the
interactive version just like inside of
anywhere else where there's HTML so it's
pretty fun and it's been like kind of a
cool a cool thing to see how people will
use that as part of their projects
because this is essentially you know
like this is just a manual version of
what happens when you use it inside
ipython notebook instead of calling I
plot which just like handles all of that
for you you can just you know grab the
snippet and put it elsewhere where you
don't have the convenience of being able
to specify to ipython how you would like
to embed something questions comments
thoughts yes yeah yeah so you can do I
mean we have a couple hundred thousand
users who just use our free public cloud
you know and it's we've always liked a
lot of the folks on our team come from
research backgrounds and a lot of like
why we've wanted to start it is so that
people will be able to get access to
great plotting tools and collaboration
tools without having to pay thousands of
dollars for them so you can do unlimited
free public plotting and then we also
give away edu accounts for folks who
want to do have like educational
projects with it and then if you want to
run it offline or on your servers then
we have licensing for that but you can
do as much free unlimited plotting as
you want to yep yeah yeah and you can
keep I mean you can keep things public
or private just from within your
notebook too
it's just we just have a world readable
object that you can set but yet so it's
still so it goes to our servers but if
you set it to world readable then only
you know logged in users with whom the
plot is shared can see it so you can use
it in that way and we don't we don't
make IP claims to it it's your data like
we don't you know we're not in the
business of trying to trying to claim it
as ours does that answer your question
cool one other thing that I thought
would be fun to show is this is a double
pendulum simulation and it was actually
we did this inside of again inside of an
eye Python notebook and then the fun
thing is is once you've made it in a
notebook then you can just like publish
it and it has its own standalone URL
that goes with it so this is using our
our streaming API and then we just
pushed Maps two weeks ago so I figure
this would be kind of fun to use so this
is a pretty fun one this shows again
using a lot of pandas and inside of an
eye Python notebook that we published
here this shows the number of new
Walmart stores per year and then mixes
it with some sub plotting here and so
it's pretty cool because you can
actually just zoom in on side of in in
each one of them so it's a it's a pretty
cool pretty cool way to be able to
toggle with them and all of this is then
just you know you can get at it from
Python a lot of like the project
mentality that we've had is kind of like
how can we make a really cool GUI and
series of intuitive wrappers around d3
because d3 is awesome but if you don't
know JavaScript or if you want to just
use Python you know it's a little hard
to get at questions thoughts yes
we recently ran some tests around that
this shows the results of them if you go
to plot data Y slash benchmarks you can
see this for yourself the general
generally you can get comfortably like
20 30 40 K points per plot if you're
doing if you're using like histograms or
box plots that are doing calculations
you can often get more in if you're
using our offline product you can plot
with millions of points because it
doesn't have to yeah but and but we're
working on a new web GL back-end that
would let that would permit a lot more
so it's you know at that point you can
put in millions of points but for right
now a lot of it is you know eventually
because we're using d3 the Dom will fill
up so we don't actually throttle you we
don't set any limits on it you'll you
find them because your browser finds
them for you if you have limitations so
but this is it this is a useful starting
point for you but yeah I mean you should
be able to comfortably get 10 20 30 K
into most of the plot types other
questions cool well that's all I had
feel free to come up and say hey
afterwards did you have a question yeah
yeah this is all just basically I mean
if you just go to plot del Y slash
Python you can see all of our Docs there
and that's probably the best place to
see all of this check out our ipython
notebooks and then all of the different
plot examples have the versions of them
but yeah thanks for coming I'll be up
here if you want to come chat afterwards
you